Okay.
Turns out to be true of chimpanzee.
So Frans de Waal,
who is a Dutch primatologist,
very smart one too.
He's been interested in the
biological basis of morality as well.
Um,
and he,
he's written a lot of good books on,
on,
on primate behavior.
Chimps in particular,
chimps are brutal creatures,
man.
Like they go to war a.
And so if you have a chimp
territory out in the jungle,
then the,
the juveniles will,
the males in particular the band
together in groups of four or five.
There's often but not always
a female or two with them.
And if they come across chimps from
another truth that aren't within their
hierarchy,
let's say they will,
if they're,
if they outnumber them,
cause they can't really count,
but they can estimate magnitude visually.
It's not the same as counting.
Um,
but if they outnumber them,
they will tear them to pieces.
And chimps serve at least twice as strong
as a really well developed human male.
And so they can tear you up pretty good.
And chimps are perfectly capable.
They hunt there,
they're carnivorous.
I like human beings and they hunt.
They hunt colobus monkeys often they weigh
about 40 pounds and they'll basically
eat them alive at monkeys screaming away
like mad cause you know it's in pain
cause it's being eaten.
And um,
that doesn't slow the chimps down a bit.
There's no cross species empathy
stopping them from having their snack.
And so chimps are very
brutal creatures and uh,
it isn't obvious they have a lot of
internal inhibition of their aggression at
all.
Most of the inhibition is sociological.
It's out in the hierarchy.
And so the reason chimps aren't always
aggressive with one another is because
they know who can pound them and,
and who will gang up
on them and who won't.
They establish their hierarchy.
Anyways.
You know,
you think about a champ hierarchy and
you're talking about a fairly strong and
aggressive creature.
You might think it's biggest,
ugliest,
meanest,
most vicious,
irritable,
unpleasant chimp that rises to the top.
While that's kind of the
postmodernist view of human society,
but that's not the case.
It happens sometimes.
But what happens,
and dwell has documented
this quite nicely,
is that tyrant,
chimps lead unstable regimes.
Now,
you know,
that might sound familiar
because the same thing,
of course it's true human beings.
Why is that?
Well,
it's because you know,
people don't like tyrants and chimps
don't like them that much either.
And chimps are actually quite
reciprocal in their social interactions.
So they don't just dominate each other.
They groom each other,
they have friendships,
they can track social relationships
over very long periods of time.
No,
and they do that.
And so they engage in
reciprocal interactions,
let's say prosocial
reciprocal interactions.
And you might think,
well,
what's the,
what's the weak point of the biggest,
ugliest,
toughest chimp in the troop?
And that is,
he doesn't have any friends.
And so,
you know,
maybe has a bad day,
he's a little hung over or whatever for
meat and fermented bananas or whatever
he is partying with.
And two of the slightly less ugly,
less slightly less mean,
chimps decide,
well this is a good time to take 'em out.
And they tear him to pieces.
Okay.
And so one of the things do all
his pointed out quite nicely,
is that if you want to have a
stable chimp dominance hierarchy,
let's call it a regime,
the stable ones aren't ruled by the
tyrants because the tyrants get taken out
by,
by paired up friendship dyad,
something like that.
So that's really worth thinking about too,
you know,
because,
because it indicates that
even in creatures that have
less complex sociological
orders,
and they do,
because one of the things that predicts
how complex your social order is,
is how big your brain is
compared to your body.
It's encephalization essentially.
And the more encephalitis to creature,
the larger the social groups it can track.
And of course,
human beings are very highly encephalite.
So we have quite complicated group.
Um,
we have quite complicated
group organizations,
but even in simpler group
organizations like the chimps,
it isn't the tyrant who rules stabling.
And that turns out to be
also incredibly important.